you have a small business own let's say
a guy who owns a dry cleaning store he
starts marketing and he sees another guy
who's marketing on the same platform as
him and he's like H I'm splitting the
pie in half it's me this other guy and
then two other guys start marketing on
the platform and now he's only got a qut
of the pie he's very sad and so what
most people think their Market is is one
method one platform one medium when in
reality you've got warm Outreach you got
cold Outreach you got posting content
you got running ads you've got that
across Facebook YouTube Instagram
Twitter LinkedIn Hulu Spotify radio TV
ad newspapers like the list goes on they
think that because somebody else is
running an ad they somehow split the pie
when they haven't even gotten a seat at
the table yet